Before I begin,
just wanted to throw out a quick
shout out to uh, everybody
for 300000 subscribers, which uh, we hit
about two days ago. So
those watching on YouTube,
a very hearty thank you. It's
a big milestone for me. It
was great to see that number and like
I always say, every sub counts. And it's not
the biggest chess community on YouTube
but it is uh, an
incredibly loyal, uh, community.
It's an amazing fan base. The comments
are always super wholesome and
um, I could not have dreamed
of      a more
wholesome, uh, community that is
more dedicated to improving
and uh, it allows
me to uh, do what I love
doing and to do it without having
to    um,
alter my kind of
rules. At the end of the day, I'm just a
chess player. I don't think I'm ever going
to play the clickbait game or the thumbnail
game as well as some other
YouTubers and I don't begrudge them that.
But at the end of the day, a smaller but
more   loyal community I think
is always worth it. And so the next
milestone is going to be 400K.
Hopefully we can do that sometime in
2023.
Um,    but if not, that's
also fine. But anyways, thank you to
everybody for subscribing and supporting.
Let's get started.
So we are 1280 and
this speedrun is moving faster
because I didn't start by
stabilizing my rating and that was a
deliberate choice. I want to spend more time
between, let's say 1000,
301,700,
uh, incorporating a lot of the feedback
from Chat. We're playing a 1400, so a
very decent player and I feel
like we've had the white pieces in like
every game, the speed run, but we've got
white again, I'm not complaining. And we are
facing E four, B six. Now surprisingly, we
face this move a very
healthy amount in the speedrun. Um, I would
say we faced it over the all of the
speedruns maybe five or six times. And
every time I've rolled
out a system that is kind of my
official recommendation against B six.
It's an incredibly effective system
and it really
neutralizes a lot of the fun that is
associated with this offbeat opening. So we
of course start with Z four. Just a second
guys, that'll let some air into the
building. And after bishop B seven, we start
with the simple move knight to C
three. This of course,   very uh,
natural in order to defend D four. And this
is the first fork in the road. So if you
don't really know anything about playing
against B six, you might be tempted
to just keep developing with knight G
one to F three. But if
you do know something about this setup,
then you will know that one of Black's main
ideas is to deploy the
dark squared bishop to before.
And the point of that is not
just to pin the night per se,
it's also to apply pressure on the e
four pawn. And a lot of white players get
in trouble because they sleepwalk through
the opening and they end up blundering the e
four pawn. And I'll show you
a couple of common mistakes that are made
against this system after the game. But the
way that you neutralize this,
um, is to
start with the move bishop to D three. Good
job, Sid, for pointing out this move. And
after bishop before. Who can remember?
And this move is really the
crux of this system.
Where do we position our knight
on G one, or do we play 83? What's the
move here?   What's the move
here?    Very good.
And most of you are getting it. The move
is indeed 92. Notice that I
didn't say nine g E two. I said
92,  uh, because the other night
cannot move. Uh, so, technically,
in notation, it's considered
92.   And, of
course, the point of 92 should be
immediately clear. We are connecting the
knight. So we are taking the sting
out of the bishop capture on C
three, and by extension, taking the sting
out of the bishop on B four itself.
Now, the move A three is
not a big mistake, but it encourages
Black to take the knight on C three, which
not only ruins the pawn structure, but
removes a defender of the E four pawn. So
after A three, bishop C three,
BC three, let's say knight F six, the
pressure on E four becomes rather annoying.
As it stands, there is well, the only threat
in this position   is knight takes E
four, but that's a very easy threat
to defend against. And notice we don't
need to play F three. We don't need
to specifically defend upon again.
All we really need to do is
get out of the pin. That's why we put the
knight on E two, so that we don't have to
worry about bishop takes C three. Well,
what's the best way to get out of the pin?
We don't even need to play a three. Like,
literally, all we have to do is literally
run away from the pin with our king. We
can just castle kingside.
And in a way, this is better than playing a
three. It's a little bit more flexible than
playing a three because, uh, the bishop
on B four is utterly
harmless. It's not affecting our
position or our development in any way.
And oftentimes you actually see
players taking on their own
volition. And if that happens, then we've
saved a tempo on the move A three, if that
makes sense.    So,
notice how compact our setup
is. E four is well defended. We are
basically ready to push e five,
especially, uh,   if Black castle's
Kingside and our bishop is nicely
positioned aiming at the H seven pawn. So
you should already kind of begin to see the
preconditions of a kingside attack, and the
queen from D one can easily
drop into H five. All we would
need to do is move this knight
out of E two so you can kind of see
the attack already crystallizing. And there
we go. Bishop takes e three is played.
That's definitely a positional mistake by
our opponent, because just giving up the
Bishop pair like that is
definitely not a good idea.
Um, so now we've got a
couple of moves on the horizon. Of course. E
five. Uh, the dark squirt Bishop
can come out to G five. That looks like a
really nice square, especially
because, given the absence of
the Dark Squirt Bishop, this
pin is actually very dangerous
for Black, right? Because
black can't just play bishop B Four to E
Seven to neutralize the pin. There's no
bishop on before anymore. And so Bishop
G Five would either force black to
make major weaknesses on the king's
side or,    uh,
to move the queen out of C Eight, and then
we would be able to capture the night. But
all of it is a moot point. Our opponent
plays a good move, h six. He's alert.
He's, um,  alert.
And that means we need to
amend our developmental
strategy a little bit. Now, we've
got a great position, and in a great
position, there's often going to be
three or four ways of
continuing. But in the speedrun, we're
trying to play very principled chess. I'm
trying to play exactly the way
that I would play it at GM level. And I'm
trying to show you what principled
opening play actually looks like. So I'll
point out two alternatives, and then we'll
go for the more principled of the two lines.
In principle, basically just means
ambitious, right? The main line.   Uh,
so, of course, if you wanted to just
develop your pieces, you could do it in a
variety of ways. Some of you are pointing
out rookie One, that's a perfectly healthy
move. Others are pointing out
bishop C One to F Four, or even a
more modest developing move like Bishop E
three. There's nothing wrong with that at
all. Bishop D Two was maybe a little bit too
passive. That's a little bit awkward. If I
were to move the bishop, I'd probably
go to E three. Thank you. Jordy drop for the
five subs. Okay, so that's one approach,
right? That's one bucket. Another
bucket is to expand our
control of the center with
a, uh, move like F two, F Four.
But I don't really see the point of that
move because I already like how we're
controlling our center. I don't really think
we need a third pawn in the center. Now, F
four, you could try to push this pawn down
to F five, and
that's in a way kind of similar
to where we're going to play. We're going to
play on the king side, but we're going to do
it in a slightly more efficient manner.
So that's kind of the second idea. But
the line that we're going to go for is
actually E five. We're going to play the
move E five. And this
move should not make sense to
you unless   you're
already sensing what our follow up is. From
a positional standpoint, e five is not a
good move.   And the
reason it's not good positionally
is because, well, we're opening up
the diagonal for Black bishop
and we're offering Black a
nice square on D five for their
night.    So those are the
drawbacks of the movie V five. But the
strength of V five is very specifically tied
into our next move. And the reason
our next move is so strong
connects directly to Black's
lack of a dark squared bishop, right?
So Black's lack of a dark squared bishop
means that the dark squares and the ponds
that are on dark squares are going to be
very poorly defended on the Kingside.
Combine that with Black's lack of
development on the Queen side, black
hasn't developed their night. The rook. I
mean, all of the pieces are kind of dead.
The ones that aren't dead are clustered on
the Queen side. So if we
divide the board into two segments, the
kingside and the Queen side,
what's happening on the kingside? All Black
has there is a king and a rook that's not
mobile. So what we need to do is
pounce as quickly as we can and
make Kingside threats and try to induce
weaknesses. And the best way to do that, as
many of you are indicating, is indeed to
drive the Queen out to G four. Uh, a
very typical attacking move across
really all openings. Anytime there's a weak
pawn on G seven. You see this very often in
the French. I would say that most commonly
you can see this move in action
in the French window. And that's
not a coincidence because in the win hour,
black plays an early bishop before takes C
three. So we see a very similar kind of
structure and scenario.
So a couple of important
remarks here. Black can't castle
because we take on H six, a
typical pinning motif, and white wins
on the spot.    Uh, Black can defend the G
seven pawn in a variety of ways. The move
king F eight is possible, although
incredibly awkward.     The move
that maybe some of you all are thinking
of here is G six. But you should
kind of visually notice
that G six creates massive weaknesses on
the king side. In particular, it makes
this big hole on F six that we're
going to try to occupy with our knight
rook. G eight also
fails to a concrete tactic as our
opponent is thinking, can anybody tell me
what we're going to do against the move from
rook to G eight? And as a hint, there
is a move that's actually better
than bishop takes H six, which is
possible. And I know a lot of you are
thinking that. But there's an even better
move.   And that move is bishop D
three to h ah seven,   we chase the rook
away, and then once the G seven pond
collapses, the entire kingside
falls apart immediately.
So. Rook G, eight. Bishop H,
seven. If Black plays G six, then
of course we play knight C three to E
four,   and then we
knock the knight out of D five with C two,
C four, and we try to put our knight on f
six. And if black plays king
f eight, let's try to figure out what
we're going to do. Well, the moment king f
eight is played, you should notice that
there is a relationship between the rook on
f one and the king on f eight. If the F
file opens in that scenario,
the king is basically just
toast. So a pretty automatic move
against king f eight is just to shove the
pond down to, ah, f five, which you
might say, well, didn't we reject this a
couple of moves ago? Well, the situation has
changed quite a bit. Right. The king is now
on f eight, the queen is now on G four.
So the effectiveness of this
has greatly increased. If I were playing
black, what I'd probably do here is actually
go king f eight and then wait
for F four and then go G six
to try to halt the progress of the f pawn.
But that is a pretty sad
product for Black. Obviously, white is
still, uh, attacking, and we'll cross that
bridge if we get there.
They're in a relationship.
Yeah, it's not exactly the most healthy
relationship,    uh, I've
seen. So our opponents sinking into a deep
think and playing a
fourth move, which I haven't mentioned well,
we kind of mentioned this move. G five is in
the same general category
as G six. I would even argue that
G five is a more weakening move. Now,
anytime you see a pawn like this on G
five,    that pawn
is actually a good thing for White. You
might be annoyed by the presence of that
pawn, but that pawn could be used as
kindling to kind of get the
kingside fire started.
And normally there are two ways of doing
that. If Black is already castled
kingside, then you might be familiar with
the idea of playing H four. In this
particular scenario, what we really want
to do is open up the F
file. So the equivalent way of doing that
is just to play F four, which is an
excellent move in this position, a move that
we actually might play. But we
should also consider the alternative. And
the alternative, uh, of course, is knight C
three to E four, intending, uh, the
old idea, right? C four and the night f
six. Check. And that looks really, uh,
really, uh, cool as
well. But actually, given that
our opponent played the move G
five,    I don't think I can
refuse f four. F four is
just so juicy here. Imagine
if the f file opens up.
I mean, all hell
is going to break loose on the kingside.
But before we play f
four,    it's always good
when you play a committal move and f four is
a committal move. You're pushing a pawn on
the king side. It's important to kind of
forecast what could possibly go wrong.
What is it that we're trying to avoid here?
Well, the scenario that we're trying to
avoid, there's only one. And that's the
scenario where Black manages to
escape to the queen side.
Right. Well, queen trade also,
but that kind of goes without saying. But
if Black can quickly get
their queenside pieces out, knight C
six, queen E seven, castle
queenside, and we've opened up the G
file that could actually backfire because
you could imagine a reality where Black then
puts a rook on G eight and it combines with
the bishop on B seven to attack g two. So we
actually need to do a little bit of
calculation to ensure
that that's not going to happen. Let's try
to concretely look at the move f four. So
after f four, black basically
has to take on f four. Otherwise we take on
G five and we win. So G
takes f four, we can
recapture with the bishop. And let's say the
Black tries to quickly get his night out to
C six.   Well, in that
case, if you look carefully at the king
side, you'll notice that there is already a
winning move. And this is a move that we
talked about a little bit earlier and that's
the queen infiltration to G seven. Even
if it doesn't capture a pawn, it's still
incredibly good because it
attacks the rook. And after rook f eight,
bishop takes H six, we're smashing
through and we're going to trap the rook on
f eight. Now Black and play this in a
slightly more, uh, astute way. After f
four, GF bishop takes f four,
Black and start with the
move queen to e seven. And the
point of starting with queen e seven
is to meet queen G seven. With queen
f eight. This is high level defensive
technique. And queen e seven is not an
easy move to play. But we've got options.
We've got plenty of options there. After
queen e seven, we could go 94. And
it's very clear to me, as it should be
clear to you, that I,
uh, mean, Black is not in time
to castle queenside. There we're going to
come up with something. We're going to have
two tempee, two entire tempe.
And our pieces are already going to
be on super dominant
posts. So I'm partially using
my intuition here to make this
determination. But we also did some
calculations. So notice how the two
combined, right, we calculated a little bit
to, uh, get a flavor of the
position. And then I basically said,
okay, I don't want to spend all of my time
figuring this out because even if
the worst happens and Black Castle's
queen side, it's not like we lose
the game, right? If you can envision the
bishop being on f four, worst
comes to worst, that bishop can drop back to
G three and act as a shield for a
rook that comes to G eight. So even
if the worst scenario comes to
fruition,  it's not like White is going
to be losing. We're still going to have
kingside pressure. We're still going to have
a target on f seven. And it's not worth
stressing about this, but I
call this the worst case scenario test.
And I tell students to do this, they
don't do it. I don't think a lot of people
do it. But it's always good when you've got
a good position to ask yourself
something that sounds pessimistic, but what
could possibly go wrong, right? What's the
worst case scenario?   And
if the worst case scenario comes to pass,
like, how bad is it going to be? And often
that gives you a good roadmap because it
immediately tells you what your opponent is
ultimately aiming for.  Uh,
and it often gives you a sense
of what you should try to avoid, which is
very important.
Now, something I failed to
mention is that Black should
probably play the move knight D five
takes f four, which, I'll be
totally honest, I kind of
overlooked. I don't think it's a
scary move at all. I don't think it's a
blunder. But knight takes f four might be
preferable to G takes f
four.   Because after
knight takes f four, the one annoying
detail is that if you can imagine
bishop takes f 4G takes f four, if we
play rook takes f four there.
What super
nasty defensive move
does Black have? Who can tell me
what Black will do in that resulting
position after everything is traded on f
four?    Yeah. Queen G
five, queen G five, and that one I missed.
And queen G five is nasty because
it pressures the G two pawn, so it actually
forces a queen trade. White is still better
in the resulting end game, but we don't
want an endgame. We want to play for
checkmates. So again, we'll cross that
bridge if we get there. But that leads
me to an interesting
insight.   After G
takes f four, I was mentioning the move
bishop takes f four. So maybe it's actually
worth taking on D five first
in order to prevent that. And maybe I should
have even done that on the previous move.
Maybe f four is a mistake and I should have
taken on D five and then gone f four.
But it's too late. Now, if Black plays
G takes f four, I think we're going to take
on D five five with the knight
and maybe even throw in the move queen to
G seven first,
so that after rook f eight, bishop takes
f four, we're on the
path to taking on H six. But
I should have done this in the other order.
I should have taken on D five first, I
think, and then gone F four.
So this, I think, was a mistake
by me, but it's still a pretty dominant
position. It's really not   the, uh, end of
the world. But after Knight
takes F four, our opponent makes us pay the
price for it.   Vince Van says all that
calculation, there was a deviation on move
one. And that, I think, is a
very realistic snippet of how
chess actually looks like, even at the
highest level. You've probably heard the
phrase long variation, wrong variation.
That's often attributed to Bent Larsen,
a legendary Danish player.
And in reality, that's
actually how things work, right? You might
not want to hear it, but in my
experience, what often happens is you go
down these long lines and then
you actually play the move, and suddenly you
discover that there is a candidate move on
the first move that you failed to consider,
and then your opponent plays it. And in
chess, there is that sunk cost
effect where you spend tons of time
calculating stuff that never happens. But
that's also where the fun is, right? Uh,
chess wouldn't be fun if that wasn't the
case, and you should just consider it as
part of the experience and part of the fun.
And in a previous speedrun. Uh, I know I'm
rambling a lot about this, but I compared it
to something my English teacher talked
about, which is called the Iceberg Theory,
which was formulated by Ernest Hemingway,
the author. And it basically
states that I think you should spend he said
that you should spend 90%,   uh,
of the time or
90% of your
character development doesn't actually make
it into the book. Like, you spend time
developing the character and 90%
of the personality traits
and the information about the character's
life isn't actually revealed in the book.
But, uh, the process of developing the
character makes the existing
10% a lot deeper. And I think something
similar happens in chess where all things
held equal. The more you calculate, the
better it's going to be, even if 10% of what
you actually calculate appears on the board.
Okay. H five. H five
is another move we didn't consider. And I
didn't consider it because I just assumed
that we're going to play queen takes G five.
And while it allows a queen
trade, it wins upon. And in the
resulting endgame, if you look carefully
after queen G five FG, well,
what do we gain from that trade? Well, we
gain the F file and
pressure on the F seven pawn
and the G five pawn. And, um, let's
take before I mouse lip the G five
pawn can be used as a battering ram. G
six is a huge threat here. And
we could still checkmate black in the
endgame, right? We've got plenty of
pieces to attack with, and we are still
very much playing for checkmate, our
opponent instantly plays D six. That's a bad
move because it totally ignores the main
threat. So, once again, who
can tell me how we should proceed with
White?  And we've got, uh,
actually a very interesting alternative
here in taking on
D six and then playing knight to B five,
trying to overextend him.
But I cannot refuse the move. G
six just looks so juicy. Open the
F file and again,
exploit Black's lack of development
while we still can.
Okay, so G six should make intuitive, this
is the kind of move that should make
sense to you if you spent one day playing
chess, right, where we're just opening up
the F file, we're paving paths for
our pieces. And as a
positive positional byproduct we're
also kind of ruining Black structure,
although that's a lot less important than
the attack,   the raging attack we're going
to have after we recapture. Okay,
so if king goes to D eight, we can
throw in another check on G five. You
should kind of quickly notice that
if the king moves to the 7th rank, which it
just did, well, the tempting move is
rook to F seven, check driving the rook into
the 7th rank.
And in a classical game, I
would basically play rook f seven without
too much thought because a move like this
simply cannot be bad. And that's what we're
going to do here. We're just going to give a
check. I'm not calculating anything,
I'm just making a move that cannot
possibly be bad.   Okay?
So, well, the advantages of having an open
file should be evident as this
game unfolds, right? This
move is the product of the
file being open. And you could ask, well,
what's the advantage of putting the rook on
F seven? Well, we're hunting the king,
right? The rook on the 7th rank
skewers all of the important stuff
that sits on the 7th rank and
it contributes directly to the attack
king C six. Now we should
start looking for checkmate, but we should
also not forget that we're simply up a
point. So a lot of people in these kinds
of positions, they actually go wrong. This
is a danger zone for a lot of players, as
uh, I have observed, because what tends to
happen is they get way too
bogged down looking for
checkmate. Forgetting that a
line where, let's say, you win another
pawn or you win a minor piece is plenty
sufficient in order to win the game. So
we should look for checkmate, we should look
for mating nets and mating constructions. We
should try to play beautifully, but we
shouldn't spend the rest of our time getting
obsessed over it. And what's interesting
is that if I was playing a bullet game
and uh,   maybe this is the move we'll end
up playing in the game, uh, what about
just knight takes D five? Like the simplest
move in the position, knight takes D five.
Right. What's the idea? Well, if the
king recaptures, we just take another
pawn on C seven. And in that position, I
feel like the king is going to get caught in
a mating net. And if knight takes D
five, E takes D five, which is more
likely, we just push E six
and that passed pawn is going to decide the
game. So another
simple move we could consider is just E
takes D six, opening up the 7th
rank. Now, I like that move less because
Black can play CD, but
that's also plenty sufficient given that we
have six and a half minutes. We're just
going to go for it. Simple chess. Knight
takes d five. No need to overthink it.
Maybe the engine would find some mating
construction. I know a lot of you were
attracted to the idea of bishop D three
because you saw bishop B five mate,
but Black is not going to cooperate. Bishop
d three. Knight takes c three.
We play BC and then we have like a
four, bishop B five. And I saw all of that,
but it's a little bit too speculative
and it's not worth it. And we might
still be able to checkmate the black king.
Nothing. Okay. King d five played. I'm a
little surprised.
Well, we, I think,
continue grabbing.
I don't see any compelling reason
not to take on C seven. With tempo. With
tempo. We attacked the bishop and now we
have a second extra pawn. And these are the
best kinds of attacks. You're obtuse pawns
and you're attacking. So there's nothing
really at stake here. Bishop a
six. All right, now,
again, let's try to play simple
chess.  And, um, in the spirit
of simple chess, there is yet another move
that I see immediately,
which is the simplest move on the board,
and it requires the least amount of
calculation. What am I talking about
here? It's not C four, it's not
B three. All of that requires calculation
because it might not be checkmate.
It's simpler than that. Just e takes d
six.   Just e takes
d six. Right. You start with a capture.
That's what you're supposed to do. I'm just
following the rules. So why is he takes D
six so good? Well, Black
is forced to recapture with
the king. That should make sense to you.
Otherwise we have a third extra pawn and it
sits on D six. After Ed
king takes D six, the key is
to see the follow up move. And if
you see the follow up move, then it should
immediately make sense why I'm so attracted
to this option. And it's bishop to F four
check.   Basically
leading to checkmate and also defending the
rook with the bishop. So we're just
going for it, Ed.   Now,
rook F eight would be a funny move here. It
would threaten made on f one.
So you should always,
always keep an eye
on things like that. Right?
If Black. Plays rook f eight here. I know a
lot of players would just kind of quickly
play D seven, but again, it's
the worst case scenario test. The reason I'm
aware of this is because we haven't yet
developed our queen side. And
anytime that's the case, you should be on
the lookout for various ways to punish
that.   So Marion district
asks, are, uh, there suggested rules of
order to look at moves? Well, checks and
captures, right? You start with checks and
captures. So I did briefly consider the move
C four check, which some of you suggested,
but I didn't understand it because Bishop
takes C four and we're at a
dead end.    Then you
look at captures, right? Then you look at
Ed. So I was literally just following the
rules. That's all I was doing. And we get
the bishop out with tempo, and the rest
should be a cleanup task.   So
my instinct in this position is to bring the
last piece into the game, rook to E one.
But if we look a little bit more
carefully, we might discover a mating
net.   Um, let me think
for a second here. I do want to do something
pretty,    and I
have an idea. I'm trying to see
if it works. It's a really pretty mating
construction, and I think it
works. Oh, this will be really cute
if this works.     Yeah, this will be
really cute if it works. Now, there's
multiple mating constructions, right? Rookie
one is plus 1000 because Bishop comes back
to E four. And I'm violating the rules of my
own speedrun here in trying to play
for beauty rather than playing for
efficiency.
Uh, and Black has a way
of okay, but we're going to start with
bishop to E five. This is the start of the
mating net.   And what is the point of
this move? Well, the point of this move is
just to defend the D four pawn with
tempo. Now, the king is out of escape
squares. And anytime the king is out of
squares, just by definition,
you start looking for checkmate.
You start looking for mating constructions,
target positions. And I see two mating
constructions here from either
side. Rookie one and bishop to
E four is a mate, but the pretty
mate is B three and C four
mating with a pawn. Notice that after
B three, black can play the move B
five to prevent C four. But anytime
a pawn is pushed, you ask yourself what
squares are weakened as a
result. And you should quickly see that the
C five square becomes accessible to Black
stroke as another checkmate.
Okay?
Now there's a really pretty
detail. If Black plays the move
rook H eight to C eight.
And all of this,
you might be rolling your eyes at this and
saying, well, we're totally winning. Like,
anything wins here. Why am I
spending so long
being pedantic about this? And
again, it's because this is where you
develop skills, right? It's the low
stakes positions where you can really drill
down and figure stuff out.
Now, my opponent played what I hope you
would play, because here we have a really
pretty idea. Don't try this at
home.   But, uh, what should we now
try? Well, we should consider our two mating
moves and actually both of them end up
working. Let's start with a move B
three,   B three threads C four.
What is our opponent's idea? Our
opponent's idea is to take the bishop on G
six, thereby opening
up an escape path for the king through E
four.   So B three
looks like a terrible blunder, but let's
extend our calculation by just one move. B
three. Rook takes G six
white to play. There is a slow, quiet,
and absolutely deadly
move in that position. And
Black Death just found it. B three. Rook
takes C six and rook to E
one, depriving the king of the last escape
square and threatening C
four. And in that position,
it's still not over. Black can deploy the
knight to C six   in order
to intercept the rook's
connection to C four. But in that position,
we have another checkmate in
one. And again, it stems from the
fact that when a piece moves out and
Black has so many squares to keep track
of, there's going to be new mating
constructions based on what Black did. And
all of you are seeing it. Ah, this is
awesome. The move is rook to D seven.
Checkmate in that position. Let's go for it.
We play b three. And yes,
we could also start from the
other end. We could also start with rookie
one. This is a symmetrical construction.
Rookie one, rook takes G six. B three would
also work.     I wouldn't necessarily
recommend this to you in a real game because
the stakes suddenly get high. If this
doesn't work, all of a sudden we're down a
piece and you risk
messing this up.   So
a totally viable
continuation would be, of course, to play
rookie one in this position, but it would
also be to play a move
like I don't even a bishop. Well, bishop D
three is probably bad. Like, bishop F seven
here would be simple and there would be
nothing wrong with it, maybe even bishop
two, H seven, to keep
control over the E four square.
But this is the clinical method.
This is the clinical way. And
let's see if our opponent even sees rotate G
six, which is not a given.
Why is bishop D three bad? Because if you
notice after bishop D three and the
trade, our pawns lose their
mobility, our pawns lose their
mobility, we lose the possibility of playing
C four. Yes, our opponent goes for it. And
the king is suddenly quite safe on D five
in that resulting position, of course, still
completely winning. And there's actually a
very cute mating construction that we could
try to build using bishop d
three, but, um,   it's not
the efficient way.
Yeah, Seth, that's exactly
what I was thinking. But I thought night a
six there and black might be
able to survive.
So
a technique that I recommend
to people, if you have time for
it and you're trying to test whether
a certain construction actually leads to
checkmate, this is especially good if it
involves a sacrifice on your end and if
the stakes are high, right? If you're
really trying to ensure whether something
works, what you can do is actually put on
your computerized and literally look at
every single legal move from your
opponent. And that takes a lot less
time than you would think, because you can
go piece by piece. You could take the queen,
then take the rooks, then take the bishops,
knights, pawns. And there aren't actually
that many legal moves available in a
position. So you do that in order to ensure
that you're not missing a hidden defense in
a given position. Let's do that here.
Okay. The rook cannot move on a eight.
The rook on G six has only one move that
avoids checkmate. That's rook takes G two.
And that obviously doesn't work. The bishop.
B, five. C, four. B. Seven. C, eight. All of
that doesn't defend bishop
D three. We still play C four. Bishop e two.
Well, that is a defense, but we play rook
takes C two.
Bishop f one. We play C four. Okay.
Knight, knight, D seven, we play C four.
Knight c six. We already discussed rook to D
seven is mate pawn moves. H four
doesn't help. B five didn't help because
of C four. That's literally it.
That was it. The king has no moves.    So,
in many cases, actually looking at every
legal move is a good way of checking
for these freak
defenses.
Um, and we have
checkmated our opponent in 23 moves, but a
very rich game. A lot happened in those 23
moves. So a lot to talk about in our
analysis.
Let me pull up the game.
All right, so we've had
this particular line already quite a few
times, bishop to D three. And I won't
necessarily delve into all of the details
again,   but, uh, since this is the
opening speedrun, we're going to do a little
bit of opening analysis here. So, in
this position, the interesting thing
is that bishop before, I believe, is
a serious mistake. Well, not a mistake.
It's a big inaccuracy. And
after 92, it's already like
plus one, according to the engine.
And this is
why bishop D three is such a tricky move.
Because when you're taught this line from
the black side, you're taught that
bishop D four is the natural follow up
to almost everything that white does.   So
we have a couple of questions here. First.
Uh, of all, Klumar is asking, why not a
three? And a three is one of white's best
moves. There are many ways to
get an advantage against one B six.
The reason I don't like this move as much is
because it's not very efficient. And after
night F six, I didn't find anything
overly convincing for white when I
analyzed.   Uh, I think the line
goes E five, knight to D five. And you get
kind of a weird alika in here.
Uh, but in any case, I
wasn't totally convinced, uh,
by this line. For white,
of course, it's also an advantage.
So after bishop D
three,   the best move for
black   is probably
to play knight f six, actually
to switch gears and to start by
developing the night. And
here you still play the move knight G
to E two. So this is a compact setup that
works no matter where black puts their
pieces. And I want to show you all
a very important line.
So oftentimes,
black can play this like a ah, French. Black
plays the move D five. And
naturally, you respond to the five, at which
point there are two viable retreating
moves. The first is to move the knight
back to D seven. Now, who can
tell me why? White has to
be very careful in this position? What is
black's threat? And I don't use the word
threat lightly. This is a serious
threat. And if white ignores it, white could
end up being worse very quickly. Yeah, the
move is C five. Now, you might say, well, C
five isn't dangerous in other openings.
Well, that's because you have the
possibility of defending the pawn chain
with C three. Here, you
don't. So things could go downhill
quickly. For instance, after C
five, if you play the move F
four, you lose your bishop to C four. And
I've seen people blunder like this. Now,
funnily enough, white is still better here
after, uh, F five, white and sack the
bishop. But it's not worth going for it
because white is a much better move. The
move here is knight F four.
And if black persists with C five,
there is a beautiful tactical shot that wins
the game on the spot. That's why
this is such a dangerous line. Let's
see if anybody can find this idea. It
exists in different openings.
Okay, very
good. Knight takes C six is correct
knife E six, forcing the
pawn off. And now the queen drives into
H five, and the game is over. Because if
G six, then of course,
of course, bishop G six
takes king E seven, and white wins every
one of black's pieces. After bishop G
five, if black plays the
immediate king E seven, which is, relatively
speaking, more resilient. And there is yet
another beautiful idea. Bishop G five
check forces knight F six,
E-F-G-F. And now the coup
de gras. Bishop takes F
six, king takes F six, and a
beautiful retreating skewer. Now, it's
very important that at the end of this
line, the bishop has no way of moving away
with check. I have made this point before.
You always have to check for this. If a
line ends in this kind of scenario, right?
If white's king was on D two, black would be
winning after bishop H six. Here there is no
discovery. White is up a queen. So the line
works out beautifully. And after
night F four, black is already in very big
trouble. The engine move here is this weird
move, G six. But it's not weird
if you understand the idea. It defends the
H five square, but still it's
plus minus. After queen G four, white
unrolls a big attack on the
kingside.  Again, C five, knight
takes C six and bishop G six
wins. So black has to play the super
awkward move, queen to E seven.
And now, according to my
analysis, the simple queen back to G three
is very, very strong. You just solidify your
position.   And if black plays C
five,    the knight
jumps into B five. Another
typical idea. And
black just totally collapses on the dark
squares. This is already plus five. So
you can analyze this further on your own.
But, uh, knight FD seven, night F
four is very bad for black. Now, the second
move involves yet another very pretty idea,
and that is 94. This is considered the sort
of more ambitious line. And
here there is another
very pretty line.   So
there is a
variation of the caro. Khan there
is a variation of the carokon
where, um let me see
if I can remember it. It says the two nights
caro. Black plays nine, F
six, white plays E five, and black
plays 94. It's a similar concept.
Does anybody know? There there's
a weird move that white is supposed
to play. Here one of the main
moves. Does anybody know what I'm talking
about?   All I'll say is that it's a
weird move.   Vince
Vance is familiar with the theory, and the
move is Nike three, D two. So there's a
concept that involves moving the knight
away. And that night was an escape hatch
for black, right? D three, knight takes C
three was the idea. Now you're
threatening to play D three and push the
knight out of the center.   Now,
black, of course, has the move queen B six,
threatening checkmate. But then white plays
D four, and the line goes on. But the basic
concept is that you move the knight away and
play D three. This is a concept which also
exists in the close Sicilian in a completely
different scenario.   So
I'll make a couple of sample moves here to
show you in the close Sicilian
an idea that was taught to me many years
ago.   So let's play,
uh, one of the main lines. Whatever.
Castles. Castles.   So this
is purely hypothetical. I will
asterisk this by saying that this isn't
necessarily good in the position I'm showing
it to you, but it's a general idea. So
in this position,
white's,  um, ultimate
idea is to remove the knight
from D four, but you don't want to do it
while giving away the dark Squid bishop. So
you come up with the idea of moving the
night away and playing C three.
Now, sometimes white can even
move the other night away to prevent
the escape hatch with knight. Take c
two and then play night C one
and then play C three. And I can probably
find you some games where this happens,
um, in a closest sewing. In fact,
I'm going to do just that. I'm going to make
a quick search and see if I can find any
examples of this actually happening.
So I prove to you that this is
not a load of BS.
But of course, as
I'm doing this, you should already be
thinking about where I'm going with this in
the context of the current game.  So
this game   clinger
is a strong im. And in this position,
watch what he does. He
plays close to selling. He plays
91,   E
six and night C one. And
after B four, he plays the move C
three chasing the night away. And then he
gets his knights back into civilization with
92. And he's deprived the c six
knight of an important square. Now
probably    White should have
considered starting with knight C one
because after 91, he gives Black a chance to
trade the knights. But I guess he wasn't too
worried about that. So in any
case, this is another similar
idea.   Now we finally
transitioned to
the position at hand that we're
analyzing and that is okay. In the car
icon, we talked about this, and
right now we're talking about knight F
692, D five, e five, and 94
having this knowledge. Who can tell me what
the top move is for white?
Try to apply the knowledge.
Why did I show you the previous examples?
What's the equivalent in this position?
And this is amazing. You guys
are getting it fantastic.
91. And see, when
you understand the idea, the move stops
looking so outlandish. It also contains
the nice byproduct that you can
now push the seat on. So
if black but the main idea is of course to
play F three and actually trap the nights
on e four. If black plays a random
move, f three wins the
game.   Night G five and
H four traps the knight on G
five, and black has to give the night away.
And if black plays C
five, trying to
counteract with C four,
then white doesn't need to hurry with F
three. White can start with C three so that
c four is not
dangerous.  And then if black plays
bishop B seven. Now again, f three
wins the night. Black is in trouble
here. According to the engine, black has to
play very concretely to avoid his knight
getting trapped. But black has to go
take stakes. Bishop B four. Check. But that
gives the B one night a nice developing
square on C three. And just look at how nice
this position looks. Queen G
four is going to be your next move. And
White's got everything on perfect squares.
The Bishop looks dumb, um,  it's plus over
minus.  And, uh, all you really need to
remember is the move night B one. Get
impressing people at a cocktail party with
it. So that, folks,
is how you meet night f six. Now
we get to the game continuation, which
is a lot easier to understand here. We
just play very straightforward moves.
Um, and I believe that this
almost busts the line. White is just much
better everywhere in this line. So
after 92 nine F six,
castles, kingside plus or minus means that
White has a clear advantage.
So in this position,
black, of course, should probably just
castle. I mean, taking on their own
volition is   a, uh, recipe
for disaster, as we saw. But even after
Black Castles, we can play a bunch
of different moves. We can play bishop g
five. But,
um, I quite like the move E
five,   which is the idea that I
pointed out during the game. And if Black
plays 95, then the game is already
over 95. Bishop d
five. And who can remind me of White's
main attacking idea in
this position? If you're watching on
YouTube, pause and try to figure out the
next move. It's a very important move and
it's a natural move. But nonetheless,
you have to remember this concept if you're
developing your night to E two.
So some of you might be thinking,
oh, it's F four, F five, but that's
slow and cumbersome. The move is
actually night to F four and the
eval is like plus five. So
let's say Black moves the Bishop back to B
seven. Just look at Black's King. Black's
king is wide open. And now you go
night to H five. Another
important idea, and not
necessarily a natural move. I think a lot of
people are attracted to queen H five,
which keeps a big advantage. Which
keeps a big advantage. But if you do
this   thinking, oh, I'm so
smart, I'm going to go night H five. On the
next move, Black is in time to play Rookie
y eight.    And if you
play night ah h five. Black somehow
defends with Bishop fate a houdini
act. And if you go night F six, check.
Of course, Queen takes F six EF, and
Black somehow gets the game into an end
game. So the way to do this is actually to
go night H five and then Queen to G four and
put the knight on F six, which is an idea
that parallels something
that we were discussing during the game.
So if Black tries to do the same thing
here and go rookie eight
other than queen G four, which wins on the
spot, we can play knight takes G seven. But
this is much simpler. Bishop f
eight. And even better than knight f
six, check is actually knight takes g
seven, bishop G seven, bishop h
six with checkmate imminence on
g seven.    So
again, it's not like after
Castles, black is okay, black is
not okay. But if black plays
the accurate move, knight to e
eight, then this is, I think, the
way to minimize white's advantage. White can
still play night f four, and this
is still very dangerous. But the knight on e
eight is an important defensive piece. After
black plays bishop c three, night C
three. I honestly feel like this is
already borderline losing for black.
It's just so, so nice for
white.     So,
okay, our opponent plays h
six, which I think is maybe the lesser evil.
And now we respond by keeping our foot on
the gas pedal, e five and queen g four.
Hopefully I did a good job of explaining the
logic behind this idea during the game,
so I won't repeat myself.
Um,   but after,
um, just a moment,
folks.
Yeah, m,   so
this is really interesting. I'm
looking up something with the engine here
just to make sure that I have the
accurate understanding.
Yeah, this is very cool,
actually.   So I discovered
something interesting
and that is that, ah, f four is actually the
correct move. So we play queen g four to
quickly reiterate why this move is so
strong. Well, it's strong because the pawn
on g seven is so weak and black's
kingside is so undeveloped, right, and
just barren and empty. So if g
six, then during the game,
I was pointing out 94 followed
by c four and nine f six. This doesn't
even deserve further analysis. This is
overwhelming.   If castles,
then of course, bishop takes H six, g six,
and bishop takes G six with mate.
So g five is actually
a sensible move from that perspective, and
we could have still played 94. But f, uh,
four is in fact the best move. And here's
the fascinating thing.
Knight takes f four is what I
pointed out as a potentially
scary,  a potentially scary
move.    Let me
remind you that after G takes f four, the
winning line is to play nine takes
D five, and then to play queen
G seven, and then to play
bishop takes f four, and black simply
cannot stop. Bishop takes h six and queen f
eight, check at a minimum. And that's just
the simplest   so
that wins the game. Now, after
knight f four, there is a beautiful
sequence. I saw this move, I was aware of
its existence, but I didn't realize how
strong it was until, uh, I
just checked with the computer.
Um,  well, I'll let people
have a stab at it. White to play and win
in this position. And it's
largely a forcing line, but it's a
relatively long line.
Yeah, rook sack, rook
takes effort. But why? Why rook takes f
four? What's the point of sacking when you
can do the same thing with bishop takes f
four. Well, the only point is to
preserve the dark squirt bishop. Well,
what do we know about the dark squared
bishop in this position? What's the key
construction? Well, we already know what the
ideal construction is here from the other
lines. And that's to start with queen
g seven    forcing
rook f eight. Uh, notice that queen g
five doesn't work because this is a check.
Otherwise there'd be made and otherwise
queen g five would work. But after a rook
cafe bishop f four, black simply cannot stop
bishop takes h six. With the battery
against the rook, it's not the
end of the line. Black will deploy the queen
to e seven will take on h six and black
will go night c six. And a lot
of newer players here, as well as
a lot of experienced players would just say,
okay, I have to take on f eight and I have
to get this endgame something like
bishop p four. And of course, it should
be a technical win for white. White is up a
pond, but there's plenty of fight
left. But there's this engine
move here that's so strong
and it's to drop back to g
five. It sounds counterintuitive, but
really it's not. You have to prevent black
from castling right. That's the threat as to
castle queenside, bishop g five
shifts the bishop and prevents it. Black has
to play queen b four. And
what do we do now? Well, now we
can employ, uh,   an idea from a little
bit earlier. We've got several winning
lines. One of them is to play night to b
five, which I know some of you are thinking
about, and then to play a three.
And then to make a
deceptively simple move in this position,
just freaking rook f one and rook
takes f seven is going to be the mating
idea. I mean, look, just just look at
this or bishop g six.
I mean, we're just going to put something on
an aggressive square and it's going to be
mate. But as I indicated, the
best move is probably to play knight to e
four and night f six with a totally
devastating discovered attack
following up. Okay, black can take one pawn
with check big whoop, king h
one. And for example, if queen takes
e five, knight f six, king e seven,
the simplest move is knight back to g
four, winning the queen on the
spot, winning the game on the spot.
So either option leads to
victory. But the key move in all of this is
bishop back to g five. Hopefully this
line made sense. And   if
I went too fast, you can always replay the
line on your own board. You can look at it
with an engine on your own, but ultimately
it is pretty force. So it should make sense
to you. Notice that after queen
g seven, king e seven doesn't work because
of this well timed check
driving the king back and then we take the
rook. What if F six
asks some of you great
question.   So the question
goes, what if F six? I assume
you mean in this position, what
if F six? Well here we can go.
Bishop g six check
king d eight. And now the best move is
e takes F six. Right, easy to miss move,
but don't rule out options that
trade. Technically it's the queen's trade,
but white's just about to get another queen
with Mate.   So definitely
really not like a very computerish
line, but nonetheless a line that
involves having to find a bunch of accurate
moves.
Okay?    So hopefully
that answers the questions. H five from
that perspective might actually be the best
that black can do here. And that is saying
a great deal. And this end game is
totally lost. Now maybe black's
last chance was to play the
proactive move night. To be four, black
must prevent G six at all cost. If G six
comes, you saw how quickly black crumbles.
So maybe night before gives them chances.
But we could still play G six. And
after night G three, we have the intermezzo
GF seven. And the engine. The engine
believes that black's best chances are to be
found after rook to H seven. Black
will win, black will win the pawn
back. But white can stick a rook
on F six beautiful square and
slide it over to G six. With bishop
H six check to follow. And the attack
is raging. This is around plus three. So uh,
obviously not exactly a
saving line.
Um, yeah, the line is findable in a rap,
even in a blitz game. But our opponent
goes D six trying to break up the center.
And, of course, g six. Yeah, z
visionzok is an alternative word for
intermedet, so that's the German term.   Um,
but G six is
totally and utterly destructive
and we don't really need to talk much about
the rest of the game, but uh, there
are a couple of nice lines that I can
showcase. So here the position really plays
itself. And the final mistake was king C
six. I mean the king on C six is
uh, just total toast.
I think the last way to keep
the game going
would have been to play king C eight. And
here again, I think the simplest is just
e takes D six, C takes D six. And
who can tell me a nice
clinical move in this position
that creates insurmountable
pressure against Black's weaknesses?
What's the surgical way to win
this? Yeah. Knight b five. Or
alternatively we've been preferring
94 forcing rook D eight. And
now C four, the same idea
as V four. And after the
knight moves away from D five, we can deploy
the bishop to F four, increasing the
pressure on D six. And if we can force
bishop to C four, then look at whites,
bishops. And look at what they're aiming at.
D five. Rook 67 is just mate, just brutal.
And after knight eight, C six, we can just
play A three, disatching the knights from
each other and winning the game.
This is all very, very
straightforward chess, but after
king C six, knight takes D five,
it's all over as well. After
he takes D five, I was planning to play Ed
six.   C takes d
six. And now what you should notice
is that the rook makes contact with the
bishop. So   a nice idea would
be to, uh, distract the
king and you could say, oh, I see it. The
move is b. Four. And B four is good, but
black can prevent it with B five.
What's a more artful way
and a more unstoppable way to achieve what
B four achieves it's actually to
play C four. Yes,
very good guys are sharp. And
after DC, not
bishop E four, checked because of D five.
But the immediate D five drives the king
out and wins the bishop on B seven and wins
the game.   Okay? So C
four is a pretty standard idea that you
should remember.
Okay, in the game, our opponent
plays   king, uh,  takes D
five. We take another pawn,
and here we basically find the
mating mechanism. E takes d six.
Winning another pawn,
deploying the bishop to F four
and finding the mating mechanism. Now,
according to the engine, rookie one is the
fastest mate, which would totally
understand. We play bishop e five. And the
reason this is technically not immediate
mate is because black can play the pathetic
move N six.   Of
course, we can just take on H eight and it's
over.   Uh, but and after
rook H eight, the funny thing is we win the
bishop as well with check and check.
So it's not like black keeps any pieces
alive.   But, uh,
okay, our opponent plays rook H six. And
now, of course, b three is the
pretty mate.
And should black stall
to get to the boxing here? Yes, exactly.
And after rook G six, ricky one, it's all
over b five. Rook c five. This is important.
This is important. And Nike
six. Rick D seven, as happened in the game,
is also important.    Um,
otherwise, against any other movie, play C
four and then BC, except bishop E
two, which case we take. Now, I wanted to
point out a funny detail, which is that some
of you were proposing bishop D three and I
was trying to mention why this is not such a
good idea. The funny thing is that
white has a mating construction here that
works only because the pawn is on D
three. And what mating construction is that?
Well, it's to play rook C one and then rook
to C five, mate.  So
it's a very pretty idea.
But this would be a good example
of, ah, hope chest, right,
this is slow.
And black can beat white to the punch
with the move knight to a ah six
attacking the rook. Now with a rook
on C one, rook D seven would be made.
Now rook D seven is not made because the
king escapes. So here you have to basically
start not from scratch, you're still
completely winning, but it's totally
unnecessary.   B three is the
clinical way to do it. And if you didn't see
it, as I said, you can play bishop H seven
or you can play bishop F seven. But, uh,
you shouldn't go for these lines
unless you've calculated them out completely
and you're going to make some mistakes,
right? You're going to be winning and
sometimes you're going to go for mate. And
it's normal once in a blue moon  to
forget about a defense, right? You can't be
perfect, but all things held equal. This
cut throat type of chess is still the best
way to convert winning positions.  And
after Nike six Rifty seven, the game
ends and we checkmate the black king
in the center. And that,
folks, concludes our analysis. This was a
nice game. It was a short game, it was a
simple game, but it was a game that
showcased, first of all, the power of the
system, I think, against B six, which you
will face, and second of all,
the immense power of this idea, e five,
queen G four, right? When the king's side
is abandoned like this,
uh, putting a queen on G four is super
effective. And then using our pawn as a
hook in order to open up our
opponent's pawn as a hook in order to open
up files. And then, uh, just
simple chest blasting the file open and then
searching for a mating net in the end. And,
uh, that was all it took. All right,
well, I will lastly point out
that there is more theory
here.  Uh, there's night F six in
this position, which definitely,
uh,    should be talked about. Although
after bishop to D three,
most of the time, black goes E
six, sometimes black goes D six and
nine, p seven. This also exists. But I'm
sure we'll get another chance to talk more
deeply about theory. Remember, I'm trying to
introduce the theory to you in bites
portions rather than just   loading
you up with a big file and just a
bunch of boring lines. Hopefully it's more
manageable that way. And, uh,
this will be out on YouTube very shortly.
Well, thank you everybody for watching and
thanks again for watching the Speedrun. Bye.